Marjorie Taylor green did something
which had it been done by Alexandria
ocasio-cortez they would be calling for
her head what did Marjorie Taylor green
do
well she went on Tucker Carlson's Fox
news program
and just assailed New York City saying
it's disgusting saying it's dirty saying
it smells bad that people are dying from
drugs on the street and all of this is
because Marjorie Taylor green is furious
that on Tuesday she went and tried to
have a protest in support of Donald
Trump in the context of trump being
arrested on Tuesday in New York City and
she was run out of the place just run
out of the place whistles you couldn't
even hear what she was saying nobody
wanted her there more media than
supporters and so now she says it's
disgusting and it's disastrous and it's
all horrible just imagine if this was
AOC saying it about a city in Marjory
Taylor Green's District here is what she
had to say to Tucker Carlson and as it
won't shock you that Tucker Carlson
looks concerned and confused which is
generally always the look on his face
really quick since you were just there
but mayor Adams described New York as
quote his home how did his home look
pretty be neat and tidy
no his home is disgusting I compared it
to what I called Gotham City the streets
are filthy they're covered with people
basically dying on drugs they can't even
stand up they're falling over there's so
much crime in the city I can't I can't
comprehend how people live there it was
repulsive it smells bad and I just I
think it's a terrible place
there's a lot that we could say here I'm
not even going to delve into the reality
that there's an opioid epidemic that is
in the south of the United States
there's a meth epidemic I mean listen
there's there are addiction problems in
all sorts of parts of this country and
Marjorie Taylor Green's part of the
country isn't exempt but understand that
this is her anger because her protests
lasted two and a half minutes before she
was just run out of there by hecklers
because nobody wanted her in New York
City we don't want Marjorie Taylor green
back in New York and it sounds like from
what she's saying we shouldn't expect to
see her again but it's really important
also to point out
that the entire New York City is
disgusting meme is pretty played out the
truth is that New York City has a lower
crime rate than many other cities in the
United States including cities run by
Republicans like Oklahoma City and even
some cities in Marjory Taylor greens
never mind Marjorie Taylor Green's State
Marjorie Taylor Green's District which
we are going to get to it's not really
groundbreaking news that when there is a
high population density sometimes you
see more trash in different places and
this of course applies to any place that
has that number of people it's not
really groundbreaking it doesn't really
say much about Eric Adams but just think
for a second
if AOC
went on MSNBC and said I went down to I
don't know I'm not going to pick on I'm
not picking on Dalton Georgia but Dalton
Georgia is in Marjory Taylor Green's
District I went down Rachel Maddow AOC
tell us what was it like down in Marjory
Taylor Green's District I went down to
Dalton Georgia
and the crime rate is way higher than
New York City it was disgusting the
average income per capita isn't even 22
000 there's no jobs there's no money
it's filled with these dirty textile
polluting industry buildings only 70
percent of the population in Dalton even
has a high school diploma compared to 85
percent in New York City it was terrible
disgusting place
imagine if AOC did that on MSNBC about
Dalton AOC and everyone on the right
would be saying they constantly insult
our part of the country they think that
we're stupid they think this they think
that they think we're backwards imagine
how the right would be reacting if AOC
had done what Marjorie Taylor green did
about New York City but there's a
difference the difference is that it's
now popular
to say this sort of stuff about New York
City even when you're not really
breaking any new grounds so the real
disgusting aspect to this is Marjorie
Taylor green that's what I find truly
deplorable not Manhattan which is not
exactly a hellscape the way she makes it
out to be
when you're using websites and apps your
device sends out data about you into the
open who you are where you go things you
like that data then gets sold around for
advertising purposes which is why every
time I connect to the internet I use a
VPN to hide my IP address and our
sponsor private internet access is the
most trustworthy VPN on the market it's
the only VPN that has proven multiple
times in court they don't log your
activity private internet access
protects you from the prying eyes of
hackers your internet service provider
tech companies private internet access
is also super fast for streaming and for
downloads you can watch your favorite
streaming platforms as if you're in
another country like the UK to access
cool new content and with just one
account you can protect unlimited
devices all at the same time this is
really a game changer private internet
access is giving my audience 83 percent
off that's 203 a month plus four months
free go to Pia vpn.com Pacman the link
is down below